- An employee of EY, formerly
known as Ernst & Young,
has been found dead in the office
in Australia after work event.
This is what I want to talk about today.
So welcome to a new coffee break,
here on my channel, Firm Learning,
the place where I want to
help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
The death of this EY employee is
what everyone has been talking about
in the consulting community
in the last one or two weeks.
And in this video,
I wanna first discuss the circumstances
that are known in this specific case,
but then, second, in a more general way,
talk about the work-life balance,
the working hours that
you can currently expect
to find in consulting.
I will, third, talk about travel,
how much travel will be expected
from you in consulting
at this day and age.
And then, fourth, I will
make some conclusions,
what, in my humble opinion,
this means for the attractiveness
of a consulting career,
and also, how this changed
compared to the pre-corona time.
Let's start with the first topic,
the death of the consultant in Australia.
And also to make this clear,
I by no means want to imply
that the working conditions
at EY were actually
responsible for the death.
This is not what I want
to say with this video.
But if you do read the
Associated News reports,
there do seem to be some signs
that the lady involved
was indeed overworked
in the last weeks, it was busy season.
And if you read, read it in other places,
there were other consultants saying that,
especially in audit,
the sector where this lady
worked from July to September,
so the busy season where
many of the big corporates
need to complete and finalize their books,
the working hours can be crushing.
Some people talked about 70, 80 hours,
plus the work expected from you.
And the Big Four employees
from that region reported
that working in these firms
felt like running an Ironman,
being part of an Ironman contest,
where allegedly, some
seniors would tell you
that you should, quote/unquote,
"Either survive or leave."
And it was this mindset that
people were saying that,
"Well, if I needed to work like this,
"if I did it in the past,
"then it truly must be
fair for you as the junior
"to now go through the same thing,
"live through the same hours as well."
And in the specific case at EY,
there also seemed to be
some other circumstances
adding on it.
Apparently this lady was from India
on a work visa in Australia.
This can put additional pressure on people
because your visa is
usually directly attached
to your employment.
And if you do not manage
to find another employer
who sponsors your visa,
if you quit your job,
you do not meet your
visa conditions anymore,
which might even lead to your deportation.
So to some extent,
these people seem to be locked
in into their situation.
And allegedly,
some of the firms are also
taking advantage of that
by not promoting these people
and leaving them on junior positions
because they know that
they cannot really leave.
Now, as many things are still unknown
about this specific case,
I want to rather abstract the topic
to a more general discussion
about working hours
and work-life balance in consulting.
And I will take this
from two different sides.
First, I will talk about
my own humble experiences
having worked at an MBB strategy
consulting firm in Germany.
And then, I also did surveys
on LinkedIn, on Instagram,
collecting many of your inputs,
also considering the current situation
which is surely different
today after COVID.
All of this with the goal
to hopefully help you make
more informed decisions
whether you want to
join consulting or not,
so that everyone knows what
he or she is getting into.
Let me start by talking about what I know
the reality has been if you
would've worked in a company
like BCG, Bain, or McKinsey
up until the pandemic.
So typical work week looked like that,
that on Monday morning, you
would fly into the client,
of needing to wake up at four or 5:00 a.m.
because of course,
you needed to take one
of the earlier flights.
Then you would work there.
You would fly back
to your office location
on Thursday evening.
And in this time period, usually
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
it was, I'd say, the average
to work until midnight or so,
often, of course with breaks at lunch
and for dinner and so on.
So in these days,
if you were able to close
your laptop at 10:00 p.m.,
that would've been a great day.
Thursday was the day where
you were flying home.
There often you arrived home
between eight and 10:00 p.m. or so.
And here indeed, then afterwards,
usually there wasn't much
work to be done anymore.
So Thursday was already a bit more relaxed
in terms of working hours.
And then, Friday usually
was a quite regular day
often until 5:00 p.m. or 6:00 p.m.,
and then, people were calling it a day.
And this is all something quite important.
There was a big culture of
protecting the weekends,
of avoiding weekend work.
Surely, if there was a very
important business need,
sometimes you were asked to do some work
on the weekend as well,
but this was definitely
just the exception.
If by the way, you are
interested to learn more
about how such a typical
work week in the life
of a consultant at McKinsey,
BCG, Bain looks like,
I will insert a video here above
where I've discussed this
in detail in the past.
So now, the question is,
how did this change after the pandemic?
Now, we'll talk more about home office
and travel in a moment, but
just in terms of working hours,
also when I asked you,
the consensus seem to be that overall,
nothing really changed.
So the hours are more or less comparable.
Same thing, usually Monday to Wednesday
until midnight or so is normal.
10:00 p.m. would be a bit early,
after midnight would be late.
Then, Friday being a bit of a slower day,
and weekends still being free.
Now, there are some nuances to this.
Some people say,
"Well, actually got a little bit worse,"
because for instance,
the Thursday where people used to travel
and where this used to be a
bit of a slower day as well,
now it's just a regular work day
for all the people who just
work from the home office.
So actually, this added to the hours.
But then, on the other
hand, some people say,
"Well, on the other
hand side, the Mondays,
"there you don't need to wake up,
"stand up that early because
you don't need to catch
"a flight that leaves at
6:00 a.m. or 7:00 a.m.,
"so you can sleep in a
bit longer on Mondays."
So this seems to be more
or less balancing out.
Of course, I'd be interested
to hear your opinions as well.
Leave a comment if you've had
very different experiences than that.
So what is my reflection
on these working hours?
And of course, everyone is different.
The effect that hours like
this will have on people
might differ quite significantly.
So let me just share my
personal humble experience.
And I must say,
I think the most important
thing that you just need to have
in your mind as a mindset
when joining consulting
is that during the week,
you focus 100% on your work.
So you just should not
have the expectation
that in the evenings, you
have time to do other things,
meet with friends, relax
with a Netflix movie,
follow, pursue a hobby.
This would just not be
part of the reality,
and you need to be okay with that.
And for me, a joint consultant
fresh out of university,
I never really experienced it differently
after starting working.
So for me, it was just natural.
It did feel like I adapted
to this situation quite well.
And then, of course the good thing,
which I think also
distinguishes consulting
from other professions
such as investment banking,
was that the weekends were free.
So from Friday afternoon, Friday evening,
you had some free time to
really recharge the batteries
and keep up with your social life.
That being said, the hours
can be brutal though.
They differ also significantly by project.
So sometimes you have a tougher project,
sometimes an easier project.
But especially on the tougher projects,
I remember several weeks,
sometimes even months,
where I just worked so much
that I just felt so exhausted.
And for sure this would
not have been healthy
for me to continue working
in such an environment now
for years, and years, and years.
Surely everyone is different, but for me,
it was clear that at some point
I did want to make the transition,
make the switch to a more also
family-friendly environment.
Let's talk about travel
and working from home
before and after the pandemic.
And as I just shared, before the pandemic,
the schedule looked
like Monday to Thursday,
you would be usually co-located
with the client at the client location,
unless the project
location was your hometown,
this could mean significant
travel every single week.
And then, on Friday, at least
the way I experienced it,
it was absolutely okay to just
work from the home office.
The only exception being
that if your project lead
was from your office as well,
he or she might have asked you to join
him or her in the office,
and then, of course,
home office was not
possible on Fridays anymore.
So what does the
situation look like today?
And what you have shared with me
via the surveys is that actually,
there's a very significant
variance even within the firm.
And this depends on, first,
your client needs and preferences.
What actually the client wants you to do.
Second, the preferences of your team lead,
and also of your partners.
And third, to some extent,
you might even be able also as a junior
to influence these types of decisions.
And currently there are three archetypes
of client service models
that are emerging.
The first archetype is the old model
where consulting teams
are still flying in,
will spend Monday to Thursday
with the client on their project.
This does not seem to be the norm anymore,
but it's still used if
the client requests this,
if the client wants this,
or for whatever other reason
the partners discussed
with the client that this is the setup
that makes sense for the specific project.
The second archetype seems to be one
that seems to be especially
relevant for the MBB firms,
McKinsey, BCG, Bain.
And this is that you're
not necessarily co-located
with your client anymore.
Often also, the client
organizations work remote,
also from the client side,
or the employees won't
be in the office anymore.
But instead, just the team internally
decides to co-locate
in any of the offices.
And what this means is that then often,
office is being chose at the
beginning of the project.
And then, all team members
who are not originally
from that office need to come
to this office every week.
So this means that the
team members that are based
in other offices need to
fly in Monday morning,
will spend the whole work week
with the team in the office.
And then, Thursday evening,
they can fly out to
their home office again,
and then, spend the Friday
in the home office indeed.
Now of course,
the office location will often be chosen
based on the locations
of the team members.
So many team members
already based in one office,
then likely this is going to be the office
where everyone will be working from.
So for a part of the team,
this might be quite convenient.
But of course,
this means that all the other
people still need to fly in,
have all the travel that is going on.
At least for this part of the team,
the travel situation did not change much
before the pandemic, but of
course, project-by-project,
this will likely be
mixed up, so on average,
you should be better off if your goal,
your preference is to
not travel that much.
Now to the third archetype,
and this is the fully remote,
or at least hybrid model,
where people can decide
to spend the whole week
from the home office,
or at least a certain number
of days from the home office
instead of being co-located
in your own office.
This seems to be more
common for Big Four firms
what you shared with me,
but some project teams,
also the MBB firms follow a similar model.
The what is the implication of this?
Does a higher number of home office days
actually improve work-life balance?
And here actually, I got
quite mixed feedback.
So on the one hand side, I heard that,
"Yes, this does lead
to a better lifestyle.
"You have a bit more
flexibility throughout the day."
Surely, if you have family,
you might have the opportunity
to have lunch with your kids,
maybe with your significant other.
But there's also quite big
group who told me that actually,
they perceive the work-life
balance to have worsened
due to this for the reason that now,
all this time that you
usually spend in travel,
also Thursday evenings
where you were just at the
airport in the airplane,
this was usually time where
you were able to wind down,
to just relax a bit, maybe
think about some other things,
not think about work all day.
And then, again, once you arrived home,
you had more time for yourselves.
Nowadays, if you work from home,
you can expect to be
dialed into video calls
from very early morning
until very late at night
with very little breaks in between.
And this in itself is a new
level of just mental stress,
pressure on your mental health.
It wasn't there before.
We were just sitting in the team room
having eye-to-eye conversations,
spending time maybe at the
coffee machine with the client.
These are types of
interruptions and breaks
which are far less common today.
In addition to that, before the pandemic,
video calls weren't really a thing.
Yes, you often had conference calls,
but these were usually telephone
conferences, so voice only.
And this then adds to just an
additional level of stress.
We need to be sitting
in front of the camera
managing your looks and appearance.
You cannot just stand
up and do something else
while being dialed into
a telephone conference.
And all of this just
adds an additional layer
of stress to the reality of work.
And I can personally totally relate
where I absolutely understand
the advantages of video conferences.
It is surely much more
comfortable and convenient
to just talk via voice
without an image of yourself
visibile at every single point in time.
So let's now move to the last section,
and this is my reflection of
what all of this will mean
for the attractiveness
of a consulting career.
And I'd say there are some
positives and some negatives.
Let's start with the positives.
First of all,
the work from home model adds
flexibility to your schedule.
You will have more time with your family,
potentially with your kids.
I do think that this is a positive step
towards making the consulting
career more family-friendly.
In addition, you will
have some flexibility
in the staffing process to
actively choose for projects,
for studies that meet your preferences.
Also when it comes to being
co-located to the working model,
all of this gives you
agency and helps you select
the projects that best meet your needs.
But there are some negatives as well,
and for the reasons discussed earlier,
I'm a bit worried that working
from home in consulting
will lead to even more
mental health issues,
to even more pressure on the people.
Sitting in front of the screen
from early morning until late at night
being dialed into one video conference
after video conference is
surely not the healthiest way
to spend your day.
Second, I'm afraid that
the increasing trend
of working from home takes away one
of the most significant
learning opportunities
that associated to working in consulting,
and these are regular client interactions.
So in the old model, you
spend Monday to Thursday,
almost the full week
together with your clients.
You will sit together with
them every single day,
have informal conversations with them,
good relationships with them.
And in my humble opinion,
this was one of the most
significant learning aspects
of the career in consulting.
And sure, if you work from home,
you will still have video
calls with these people,
but it's just not the same thing.
And I know some people might disagree,
but also looking at my current role
as an executive in a startup company,
if you talk to clients
just via video calls
and compare those to clients you have met
face-to-face in workshops and so on,
the difference of the
relationship is so significant.
I am afraid that a lot of
these types of experiences
and learning opportunities
are now missing.
While in this video,
we talked a lot about the negative sides
of working in consulting,
I do want to stress that
I look back at my time
in consulting in a very,
very favorable way.
My time in consulting was
absolutely instrumental
to both my personal and my
professional development.
Yes, the hours can be tough,
but you will also grow
significantly with the experience.
Now, if you are currently
working in consulting as well,
let me know in the comments
whether all of this matches
your current experiences.
And of course, if you took any value
out of this video at all,
hit the like button for the
YouTube algorithm and subscribe.
Big, big thanks to all the
members of the channel as well.
My name is Heinrich.
I release videos every single week.
All the best to you, and bye-bye.